helicópteros carros blindados más de
1000 policías e incluso los cuerpos
especiales de seguridad
Brasilia no ha escatimado esfuerzos para
evitar que actos violentos se empañen la
investidura de Lula dado que hoy tenemos
dos grupos antagónicos y una atención
política muy grande nos preocupamos de
reforzar todos los hoteles que albergan
a los jefes de estado y a los
diplomáticos el aeropuerto de Brasilia
está con la seguridad reforzada todos
los puntos sensibles de Brasilia como la
torre de la tv
periodistas de todo el mundo han acudido
para cubrir la que definen como una gran
fiesta de la Democracia que la situación
Por lo menos por lo que veíamos desde
Argentina era bastante tensa se veía
bastante tensa ahora en la calle no
hemos visto este episodio este ningún
tipo de disturbio ni situaciones
violentas Pero bueno Esperamos que eso
se mantenga el domingo no
entre tanto a lo largo del día las
caravanas no paran de llegar a la ciudad
miles de simpatizantes han encarado
viajes de hasta 50 horas para marcar
presencia en una fiesta que tendrá
música en vivo hasta la madrugada se
espera que lleguen a
Brasilia estadio Mané garrincha a mi
espalda hay un campamento con capacidad
para 11.000 personas
Isaías vino del estado de pernambuco
para celebrar la victoria de Lula
pertenece al movimiento sin Tierra desde
su fundación
la lucha contra el hambre soy nuestra
lucha principal luchamos para que la
población sin tierra tenga un pedazo de
tierra para cultivar y para alimentarse
también para que podamos alimentar a la
sociedad en la periferia de las grandes
capitales con proyectos solidarios
una marea roja ha tenido una ciudad
donde hasta hace poco reinaban el verde
y el amarillo A pocas horas de la
investidura el clima es de alegría y de
optimismo